change that you know we can Implement
something in Twitter what would your
Implement be keep the nudity I'd say use
all the words you want oh like like so
like no like letter cap or anything like
that uh yo uh you're not gonna use the
words
the slur like a [ __ ] a slur or
something that's like a Chinese person
what would it be like I don't know dude
hey hey buddy I don't [ __ ] know guys
[Music]
oh we brought up this topic not too long
ago but we gotta keep on keeping the
updates on it let's keep on keeping on
more updates the largest
and impactful social takeovers or
corporate takeovers that we've
experienced
I think I know what this is there's more
there's more
I just tell you right now please that
when Elon took it over I had the best
time on Twitter in a long time it was so
fun watching everything go down it was
it was I don't know if you guys were
there but I was there were there on
Twitter No I was there sorry to be a
party pooper but who uses Twitter dude
am I tripping I've never used
but who's on Twitter my guy
Paul
[Laughter]
political [ __ ] talking and drama that
shit's great that shit's when they start
battling that [ __ ] out that's awesome
um stocks
really yeah stocks but but but like but
not like
we're all like not convinced like oh
ring okay never mind you're like that
[ __ ] uh but there's com there's
comics on there they're funny yeah but
okay I think like Twitter is a space
where you just say whatever the [ __ ] you
want that you can't say anywhere you
sound like Twitter to me sounds like the
douchebag at the bar I feel like people
are just crying they're just like
talking about oh yeah oh God he's lying
I haven't been on it in like three four
years though
I haven't done it three four years yeah
we don't have to talk about this a
little more time no I want to talk about
no no no no don't get me wrong I want to
talk about this but I'm just telling you
right now I don't know who the [ __ ] I
don't use Twitter so I didn't really
like everyone he's like took over I'm
like I don't [ __ ] what apps do you
use what what social there's a thing
called PornHub and let me tell you
something uses MapQuest dude and only
fans I'm an Instagram that's it
Instagram is awesome I don't even do
[ __ ] I'm trying to do Tick Tock but
it's like I just feel so cheesy I feel
like I'm 30 32 what the [ __ ] am I doing
on Tick Tock are you see me right there
[ __ ]
I'm like a decade older than you really
almost no I could tell the thing is no
but uh no how old you got that old
holiday yeah you're 40 dude almost
couple years you look great though thank
you you guys Asian got that skin you
know what I mean you got that look Asian
don't raise them no I took about 10
years in a crowd cryogenic chamber and I
didn't really age much because of that
reason the crypto cryogenic the crypto I
spent it I use cryptocurrency to keep
young they look great dude you look
great you look young long hair I feel
like you were transitioning but I don't
know what's going on yeah
I'm right in the middle yeah so Elon
Musk has been laying off thousands of
employees thousands I believe uh half 3
700 ish employees what's his boss move
though that's boss move why does this
feel so satisfying yeah it is what he
did he [ __ ] as a businessman he
showed over there and showed he showed
his [ __ ] privates to everybody you
know I got big dick out here he does
have a big big dick energy right there
why is it funny when I when a tech
company has layoffs but nothing else
like if if you heard this like a coal
mining company had layoffs everyone's
like oh that's so sad and you feel like
[ __ ] these guys yeah we're like
our Factory you're like all these car
facts but Union guys get [ __ ] gradu
they get a lot of money they make a lot
of money they're sweating though but
I'll tell you this this is what I don't
feel for the Twitter people is because I
don't know what it takes for
like we don't know how many people yeah
we don't have work to create Twitter to
me it's like it's like a nerd at a
[ __ ] basement like but it obviously
it's more people than that but we don't
know because on computers the custom
miners we're like oh yeah we physically
know there's something yeah you you
imagine a guy [ __ ] sweating away
hitting at a [ __ ] Stone and [ __ ] you
know and then they're just like this get
lung cancer and [ __ ] that's what you
picture right yes and then like when you
think of a tech company you think all of
these nerds that are just wasting time
at the [ __ ] they're at the they're at
the Google headquarters eating food and
just doing nothing that's what you mean
that's what I'm picturing and then when
they get laid off you're like
[ __ ] that's right and to be fair okay
nerd elon's been justifying in his
stance because he says that the social
media service was losing over four
million dollars a day
a day numbers guy yeah he's a number guy
he's like why do we need you what do you
do clean the house
get the [ __ ] out of here what do you do
you know so I like that about everyone
on his board actually was let go so he's
technically the only single individual
on the entire Twitter board right now
that's what's up because it seems like
the way he wants to run Twitter he needs
just New Vision he needs new people to
run it with him right and he needs it to
make sense and he's wrong with money
it's a business yeah but didn't he say
he's gonna do a subscription platform
for Twitter so he's turning the blue
check of verification to eight dollars a
month okay yeah that's good that's nice
60 200 but what is that [ __ ] a year
right but and the thing is hey to have a
blue check mark yeah if you have a blue
check where you're gonna pay for that
it's like an eight dollar subscription a
month or or something because before he
believed that the concept of and how
they're handing out verifications was
very like high class versus lower class
the people who deserved it the people
who got it to be whatever right whereas
his biggest thing and his understanding
of the biggest thing is all other than
the fact that it's a business that needs
to make sense to make money is also the
fact that uh there's Bots and there's
spam and if people have to pay for the
verification then they're automatically
like you know being like these are the
people that are real and then also in
the service for paying eight dollars a
month your replies your mentions your
everything you get the priority in terms
of like comments and stuff so your
actual you know dialogue or
conversations with people who are
verified are able to push like the spot
you're trying to make up that four
million yeah yeah I don't think eight
mil is that bad if you're running a
business through Twitter yeah
I heard something recently that there
was like a penalty fee or something for
firing somebody on Twitter what do you
mean uh it was like it was like 200
something 200 no no like 200 000. either
200 000 or 200 million that he has to
like pay two for like firing people
because like it was written in their
contract that if they get fired well it
might be you might be talking about
severance pay so like laying people off
means that they still have Severance and
stuff like that and he's offering three
months of severance pay which he says is
50 more than is legally required wow so
he's good but there isn't there is a
lawsuit that a couple of the board
members and different people are still
putting together as a kind of you know
they're he paid out the CEO too like
like 20 mil or something oh yeah maybe
that was the thing I was saying oh okay
maybe maybe that was maybe maybe not
yeah I don't know I don't know I when
you hear the word layoffs like you think
oh so shady right but then also the way
that major like big companies form is
there's a lot of waste there's a lot of
people that get hired just because they
need to beef up a department or this
department needs to like spend in order
to keep that budget so they're like what
are we gonna do with the money well [ __ ]
I don't know do you need an assistant
all right get three assistants like they
do [ __ ] like that and then you do
pointless work and then maybe you want
to keep your job so you have to justify
your position and your job might be
redundant there might be five positions
that do the same thing when it only
takes half of a position but they don't
want to lose their jobs right so then
they make up work this [ __ ] happens all
the time in companies and then so like
there's also um yes there's exploitation
coming from you know the top end but
there's also the groups that go in and
and do a lot of corporate waste like
spending and all that too so then all
this [ __ ] has to be continuously running
business talk
it's just talk with Joe there's like a
lot that that should be not be that we
shouldn't be spending on but they have
to spend and if they don't spend like
schools if they don't spend that budget
they lose it because they go oh that's
true you don't need that money look at
how much money you save this year so
then they're like oh no no we're gonna
need that money for next year because no
you don't he goes well let me show you
how much I need it and they'll buy all
these chairs that they don't need
because they're like see we had to buy
you want to keep that money yeah yeah
that makes sense but it makes sense for
the the people that want to keep the
money too because what if they want to
spend that next year or whatever right
it's like so there's all these games
going on and it's not as simple as like
hey he's this [ __ ] up dude firing
people because I like to protect
billionaires because one day I like to
be one but yeah you got billionaire
Vibes right now you got a little [ __ ]
Golf Club you're talking money this is
very possible CEO boss moves right now I
just like to pretend like I'm successful
already when I'm really not even got the
sandals too did he really oh douchebag
sandals oh no
oh no oh no do I look like a technical
company to squat on the chair oh my God
you're so see you all right now dude
it's not even funny dude ponytail go you
gotta let your hair yeah slow motion
though yeah you gotta let your hair flow
yeah
it can just be like nice in it so let's
talk numbers you gotta show up and be
like let's talk numbers like you don't
care you're doing something else you're
putting like because you guys are
Visionary so I got this idea for like
eco-friendly fully organic like
microchip and like yeah
can we put it in our brains man
show down dude we're gonna put in a
thousand monkeys first imagine it's like
we got to put on someone's brain
forced monkeys though so like we got him
organic and they're we got them organic
farm-raised monkeys so uh what's the
positive side about this about him
taking over Twitter yeah what's the
positive what are we hoping the new
vision of Twitter Road flag of the
vision for him was to make it truly a
place of freedom of speech uh and and
the kind of digital townhouse some
people don't like that though some
people don't like how he's like is it
actually freedom of speech if a
billionaire is coming in and running
everything and then some people are like
I liked it when it was before because
they believe that people shouldn't have
a platform
um that are in their eyes extreme
because they're like now you're letting
them build a following and get a voice
but it's it's it's it's a real weird
gray area because then according to
control what a guy can do yeah yeah who
would need to control is the whole point
that's exactly right because that's
that's kind of like why do you get to
gatekeep who gets to speak and then if
they don't match with what you believe
then they're the wrong ones
automatically so it's like I don't know
slippery slope I don't like control dude
okay yeah what's new updates with
Twitter other than the fact that he just
fired half of the people when he's
talking about how they're losing four
million dollars a day and the fact that
Diddy also was one of the people that
gave him 10 million dollars to help
purchase the thing
really yeah does he get a a piece yeah
he gets PC it literally Equity 10
million off of 44 billion he's got like
0.0 [ __ ] one four percent zero zero
but being having to see at the tables
having a seat at the table right like
when you're making moves like that so he
bought it completely right so that means
that he had to fundraise for it a lot
obviously at 44 billion just give me a
little square dude because even one of
the biggest owners of Twitter I would
say a third he would he was little over
a third of the ownership of Twitter and
it's a Saudi Arabian billionaire yeah
and one of the issues was like hey this
is an American platform and because it's
an American platform or like it's it can
affect American politics you have a
Saudi Arabian guy that might be a uh
pushing his agenda on to the or who
knows right and so that's one of the
things they're saying is like hey
um if we're gonna uh
we're gonna buy this [ __ ] we gotta make
it American that's one of the things
they were talking about this guy gets
political doesn't he I [ __ ] like it
dude I'm always waiting for it to still
connect to Field of Japan though like if
it doesn't get there I'm like man we
didn't go deep down it's like the reason
s American companies since the [ __ ]
1880s right were in competition with
Japan yeah like that's that's where I'm
hooked it's gonna be a weird [ __ ]
high buddy you just [ __ ] start
talking into government that's how we're
[ __ ] controlled okay so if we all had
it
a change that you know we can Implement
something in Twitter what would your
Implement be I'm gonna opt out of this
one because I've never used it keep the
nudity
or they are they gonna take that out no
just kidding I don't know what
I don't know enough about Twitter oh
yeah I actually use all the words you
want yeah I feel like the freedom of
speech stuff like all like like so like
no like letter cap or anything like that
like you were like I mean that's use the
words you want like if somebody says
like uh uh yo uh you're not gonna use
the words
slur like
a slur or something that's like a
Chinese person what would it be like I
don't know dude dude hey hey buddy
you're putting me in that corner I don't
[ __ ] like it dude I don't like
control I don't like your controlling me
and I don't like it dude I'll just turn
off the video are we on Hotsy right now
it's getting hot as [ __ ] here you
call me muffin ears dude
laughs